here's the question if you choose four
random points on a sphere and consider
the tetrahedron with these points as its
vertices what is the probability that
the center of the sphere is inside that
tetrahedron go ahead take a moment and
kind of digest this
question and how do you even approach a
problem like this right where do you
even
start well it's usually a good idea to
think about simpler cases so let's knock
things down to two Dimensions where
you'll choose three random points on a
circle and it's always helpful to name
things so let's call these guys P1 P2
and P3 the question is what's the
probability that the triangle formed by
these points contains the center of the
circle it's way easier to visualize now
but it's still a hard question so again
you ask is there a way to simplify
what's going on get ourselves to some
kind of foothold that we can build up
from well maybe you imagine fixing P1
and P2 in place and only letting that
third Point vary and when you do this